c'est vous qui le dites est aujourd'hui
à amboise pour parler des 500 ans de la
renaissance et à cette occasion
emmanuel macron sera ici le 2 mai
prochain
bonjour si réel un jour une tablette et
des questions nous vous écoutons
que pensez-vous de la venue du chef de
l'état
[Musique]
q pensez-vous de la venue du chef de
l'état touristes à amboise donc on
n'était pas forcément au courant que
macron elle est passée dans la région
alors la venue du chef de l'état je
pense que c'est très important pour la
ville d'amboise
après personnellement moi je vais pas y
assister
je pense qu'on sortira dehors quand même
pour le saluer six passes devant
pourquoi pas que pensez-vous de la
célébration des 50 ans de la renaissance
je pense que ça a été une époque
transitoire sur le plan historique
c'était un mélange de styles l'italie
à copier la france la france a copy
l'italie donc ce qui a donné un style un
petit peu maroc je tairai parce que
c'est important de commémorer les 500
ans de la renaissance
ça permet quand même de prendre
conscience que ça a eu un impact quand
même sur notre histoire sont notre
culture
d'un point de vue historique artistique
et ça allait quand même un impact une
révolution que retenez-vous le plus de
cette époque
ce que je retiens le plus de cette
époque ceux celles architecture
essentiellement larchitecture pourquoi
pourquoi parce que comment dire je
trouve que c'était travailler c'était
dans clé c'était
puisse toujours ce mélange culturel
entre l'italie et la france
essentiellement voilà qui a le plus
apporté à l'autre à votre avis à mon
avis je pense que l'italie à a beaucoup
apporté à la france
on pense à quoi quand on pense à la
renaissance en général les ventes et la
peinture la peinture l'art ne découverte
du monde
un enrichissement de la culture mondiale
je dirai davantage un personnage
historique françois 1er qui a notamment
pris conscience que les armes se tenait
pas qu'à la france mais à l'italie et
qu'il en a qui l'a fait venir d'italie
les a et qui l'a bouleversé changer
modifier notre vision notre regard sur
les arts léonard de vinci est mort au
clos lucé une de ses inventions vous a
marqué oui celle qui m'a marqué
c'est quand il a créé la machine à voler
c'est vraiment la machine qui m'a
interpellé pourquoi pourquoi parce que
l'homme a toujours rêvé de voler n'est
ce pas vos des inventions lui
quelques-unes comme l'hélicoptère
le char l'invention des honneurs de
vinci qui m'a qui m'a impressionné c'est
quand même
l'avion et les avec ses ailes quoi bon
c'est pas une invention mais je pense
d'abord à la joconde et après le
parachute ça a été ou pas c'est vrai
[Musique]